This is another dimension, because the handgun
is concealable.
It's a different conversation than just making
rifles.
All handguns will eventually be available
for people to produce for themselves
in the privacy of their own homes.
Gun control can never die, because it lives
in the hearts of men.
No, gun control is not dead, it's undead.
Gun control is undead.
And uh-
we just keep killing it.
But it just keeps coming back.
In 2012 a then-25 year old crypto-anarchist
named Cody Wilson started Defense Distributed,
an organization devoted to removing the barriers
from making firearms at home.
The following year, defense distributed released
the Liberator
the first 3D printed pistol.
The Liberator is a simple, single shot 380
caliber handgun.
At the time, the replaceable barrels were
only considered safe for one shot.
5 years after the Liberator debut, the technological
limitations of home made firearms
have started disappearing.
The materials are cheaper and better, the
machines are more precise
and the software is more advanced.
It's a new reality that hasn't entirely filtered
into public debates over gun control.
It outstrips people's daily experience, they
don't really understand what's taking place.
This is a ghost gun .
Because now it is very easy and completely
legal to make a firearm
in the comfort of your own home.
The era in which the government can even hope
to keep a fully functional firearm
out of the hands of someone truly determined
to get one is coming to an end.
Now I can ship gun machines that help you
crank out 1911s in your kitchen all day long
and no one has anything to say about it.
Because what is there to say about it?
By late 2014 Defense Distributed had raised
enough capital
to begin manufacturing the Ghost Gunner.
A small machine that uses pre coded commands
to remove metal from unfinished firearm parts.
Parts that when sold by a manufacturer
are legally required to contain a serial number.
What comes out of the Ghost Gunner is a key
component of an untraceable
yet fully functional metal firearm.
In late 2017 Defense Distributed released
files that allow the ghost gunner
to mill out unfinished metal handgun frames.
Wilson says the new focus on handguns is an
important step
towards the mainstreaming of home gun manufacturing.
A lot of people living in an urban setting
like DC
wouldn't consider slinging an AR15 on their
back walking around the street.
But they would at least think about whether
they wanted to have a handgun
concealed and made without anyone else's knowledge.
While a 3D printer assembles objects out of
layers of plastic or other materials
a milling machine like the Ghost Gunner does
the opposite.
Carving a solid piece of material based on
specifications spelled out in code.
Defense Distributed sells the machine for
just under 1700 dollars.
You can make a 1911 in your kitchen, make
it in your bath tub if you want
and no one has to know about it.
It's really cool and it wasn't true last year
in the way that it's true now.
Thanks to the internet, the newest generation
of homemade gun designs
are approaching the quality of store bought
firearms.
My name's Darren Booth I'm a union carpenter
start getting into 3D printing about 2014
and I was downloading different objects from
the internet, printing them out,
and I wasn't really satisfied with the way
they turned out.
So I started getting into 3D design.
And then that's when I heard about the Liberator.
I like the Liberator, it's fine, you know
it's only good for one shot
so I thought, well, what can I do to make
it a little better?
This is the latest version, the Shuty AP9.
I make them out of PLA plastic but they hold
up well.
This very gun here has probably had over 5000
rounds shot through it.
The digital files that are used to create
guns using milling machines and 3D printers
are written and shared online by hobbyist
gun printers.
Booth is a regular of the Fosscad group and
the community worked together
to make the digital files for the Shuty.
But it's an open community, it's an open chat,
anybody can go on there
and just ask questions.
I watched some of these groups begin like
on my own websites
when I used to host forums and IRC channels
and things like that.
And it's great like in our earliest days I
imagined that.
That would be what victory looked like.
There would have to be communities taking
up these projects on their own.
It's an intellectual exercise, it helps you,
you know and just it's fun
to come up with new ideas and exchange information.
And this information exchange is at the core
of the home manufactured gun movement.
The 3D printed gun was never itself.
What we developed, what we shared online was
not the gun
but it was the files that could create the
gun.
It's freeware for anybody that wants to build
it
hopefully somebody will make it even better.
The Shuty requires additional parts made by
third parties
but those components can be freely ordered
on the internet
from unregulated vendors.
Shoot a little low, a little low and to the
left.
When the only thing you need to create a gun
at home is a tiny digital file
and a trip to the hardware store,
gun control becomes impractical.
It may also be impossible to outlaw the distribution
of digital files used for handgun production.
Wilson argues that an individual's right to
create and distribute blueprints for a gun
is protected by the First Amendment.
Sharing that software was a political speech
act
and the software itself, because it can be
changed and evaluated
and understood by humans, the software itself
is speech.
So it's about fighting about that information
not about what the information can become.
In 2013 the State Department forced Defense
Distributed
to remove the download links to the files
for the Liberator,
claiming they violated the International Traffic
in Arms regulations or ITAR.
They saw these kids you know online like
'hey not only no gun control but we're gonna
destroy the whole concept
because the internet's gonna serve guns.'
They were looking for a way to put their own
power over what we're doing.
And the closest thing they could come up with
at the time was the ITAR.
The ITAR is a set of regulations that govern
what kind of military materials
can leave the US and go to other countries.
The State Department and Justice Department
say
sharing this type of information, gun files,
with American citizens on the internet
is tantamount to exporting it to foreigners.
And this somehow violates a foreign affairs
power of the executive.
Joined by the Second Amendment Foundation
and the prominent attorney Alan Gura,
Wilson challenged the State Department's order.
In the spring of 2017 they petitioned the
Supreme Court for a temporary injunction
that would null the take down order until
their lawsuit was resolved.
In January of 2018 the high court declined
to hear the case
sending it back to a lower court in Texas
to be argued on the merits.
Yeah we're gonna win our case and it doesn't
meant that we have to win it in court
but, you know, we'll win in the court of public
opinion.
And that doesn't mean that public opinion
will agree with us.
In other words, the tools to build your own
firearms are already in circulation
but Wilson is trying to win legal protections
for future innovations in the space.
Defense Distributed's focus on handguns is,
in part,
a legal strategy based on the 2008 Supreme
Court case District of Columbia versus Heller
that affirmed the right to own a handgun for
self defense.
The handgun is at the center of what is protected
in the Heller decision
as everything's understood now.
So whereas AR15s may not ever be backed up
by the Supreme Court
there's no way of getting around, right now,
the protections that the Supreme Court gave
to the handgun.
And so this is the core of the Second Amendment
liberty as it's currently understood.
Now deploy-able, downloadable, manipulable,
you can do it in your garage.
And so it's a kind of temptation, it's an
invitation to discourse if you will.
Automated, off the books firearm technology
is a reality
and there's nothing anyone can do to change
that.